you know what the question I think we
get the most is what other character
would you like to play which is sort of
loaded in its own way and people always
want to know which character it was my
favorite fairytale character which is a
hard one to answer because I really
wasn't I wasn't a fairytale kid I was a
kid reading books you know well above my
years that I wasn't supposed to be
reading so that was always a hard
question because I didn't really have
the kind of answer that I think they
wanted that must be interesting in
Hawaii and playing one of the characters
who once put us on Blue Fairy yes yeah
and a character that you know I remember
when I went to go upward and I knew what
the premise of the of the show was but I
honestly didn't know who the Blue Fairy
was I had to sort it go and look her
they were like oh she's from Pinocchio
and I looked her up and she was blonde
and okay which obviously you know is not
the mo but but for many of them they
really did sort of hold true to what
those characters looked like and so I'm
just happy that I got her how'd you
enjoy planning home and about the other
parts of Mother Superior as well because
I've quite different roles aren't they
yes they are you know it was funny
because before I knew who I was going to
be in Storybrooke I really thought that
I would play somebody really whimsical
you know I was convinced that she was
going to drive like the ice cream truck
or run the toy store or something
because she was so kind of quirky and in
in fairytale land the way that that we
had come together with this ornate
costume and so when the script came and
it said that she was superior I was
really shocked and and I thought oh my
gosh like I was worried am I gonna have
to wear a wimple you know she would be
really beautiful to pull off a wimple so
and you know Mother Superior is in some
ways it's a challenge for me because I
very often play like they you know
quirky funny and Mother Superior was not
quirky or funny she's very staid and
calm and in its own way it's been a real
challenge for me to play within a box
that I'm not used to playing so what he
drew on for that character and how do
you see them both developing as the
season goes forward oh gosh I wish I
knew in terms of just you know I just I
remember Jennifer Morrison saying
something to me once about I always feel
really calm when Mother Superior is
there like she just has that sort of
effect on people when she shows up
you're like okay things are all right
and I think in terms of development I
would love to know more
about who the fairies are and how they
became who and how she became real
Gorham who was supposedly the most
powerful being I would love to know more
about that and to be able to play with
that who are the actors on set you
particularly enjoy interacting with on
the show
oh gosh ly Arenberg is always funny I
always get a kick out of hanging out
with him and you know it's it's just a
good group there's always a mix a lot of
times I'm there by myself because I'm up
on green screen and so it's not always
I'm not always there when everybody else
is there but those group scenes are
always wonderful when there's a whole
bunch of us it's a fun set to be on a
great cast and a great crew and I'm just
happy to be part of it and of course
Once Upon a Time has been so popular
what do you think the appeal of the show
is it is pretty popular yeah you know I
keep you know III think that because of
the way the world is right now things
are difficult and it's difficult
everywhere and I think when people watch
once upon a time they come out of their
workaday lives and they see these
fantastical lands and fantastical
costumes and it's things that they they
know fairy tales that we know from
childhood I just think it's a warm happy
place for people and but with the twist
you know so it's not it's not your same
old fairy tale
you